so Leute diese Geschichte muss ich euch
unbedingt erzählen ich hatte einen
Saunagang der ein absolutes Fiasko war
Hintergrund ist mein Freund Fabian
wollte immer dass es solche
metolkristalle hier sowas mal in die in
der Sauna anwendet du muss man das auf
die Sauna also einfach auf die Steine da
legen ich habe gesagt ich weiß nicht wie
stark das ist lass ich mich mal
ausprobieren wenn keiner da ist morgens
früh habe ich gemacht diese Dinger
mitgenommen und dann habe ich die mal so
da über die Steine verteilt war niemand
anderes drin setzt mich dann auf die
Bank und dann beginnt eine absolute
ebenfalls es hat sich wie eine
Katastrophe angefühlt dieser es war ein
so scharfer Geruch er hat mich Tränen
lassen die Augen haben getrint die Nase
hat gebrannt es war wirklich furchtbar
ich war heilfoh dass niemand anderes da
war aber dann wurde es schlimmer dann
fingen diese Steine Feuer plötzlich so
fump und ich so okay das war jetzt nicht
so geplant wie gesagt noch war niemand
anderes drin ich B nur lass das schnell
vorbeigehen dann auch die Flammen wurden
ganz schnell kleiner waren weg aber
dieser Geruch der wurde noch beißen ist
wirklich es war absolut wahnsinnig und
ich dachte hoffentlich kommt jetzt
keiner rein hoffentlich kommt jetzt
keiner rein es kam keiner rein aber der
Geruch ging nicht weg dann habe ich mir
okay ich habe noch eine Flasche mit dem
anderen aufkusch mit Wasser gieß ich
jetzt schnell drüber und tatsächlich
danach ließ ist einigermaßen nach dann
kam jemand rein der hat sich auch nicht
beschwert Glück gehabt aber dann zum
ersten Mal in der Sauna fange ich an na
ja fast zufrieden es wurde mir kalt und
das bei 90° Celsius also es wurde
wirklich durch dieses mentol in der Luft
mein ganzer Bauch wurde kalt okay dann
nach knapp 20 Minuten raus und dann kam
das Grande Finale ich habe kalt geduscht
und das war jetzt keine kalte Dusche das
war eine absolute eisdusche das hat sich
angefühlt wie viele viele kleine Spitze
eisnädelchen die auf mich
niederprasselten trotzdem habe ich es
eine Minute ausgehalten dann direkt in
die dampfsauner und dann wir's langsam
besser